foreign
this was the moment caught on amateur
video cameras at 607 am local time in
Crimea purportedly showing a cargo track
exploding on the motorway parallel to
the catch Bridge the blast was so huge
flames and debris crossed to the other
lane and reached a fuel cargo train that
was passing by Russia's government was
quick to respond the speaker of the
state Duma described the incident as a
terrorist attack and an act of War on
Russia President Vladimir Putin has
ordered an investigation committee be
set up to find out who's behind it and
how it happened
the Kirch Bridge also called the Crimea
bridge is one of Russia's most vital
supply lines and its only land link with
the Crimean peninsula
it was opened by Vladimir Putin in 2018
four years after Russia annexed the
Crimean territory from Ukraine
the explosion caused two sections of the
bridge to collapse and several train
carriages caught fire
traffic on the entire Bridge came to a
standstill
the sea ferrying Arch under the bridge
was not affected but this will likely
pose several challenges for Russia's
capabilities to supply its troops and
other administrative operations in
Crimea
the Kirch bridge is less than 300
kilometers away from the nearest battle
sites in Herson and here in Mainland
Russia no one seems to doubt the
incident is directly linked to the war
in Ukraine and every finger of
accusation is pointed at kieval
al-jazeera Moscow